well the reality is that wage growth is
stagnant rising to just five hundred and
eighteen pounds a week if you believe it
that's just a pound more than it was
this time last year and that rise of not
point one percent is the smallest since
1997 and that means in real terms when
you account for inflation the average
amount we're paid is now back to the
same level it was nearly a decade and a
half ago in 2000 now the financial
crisis triggered this decline you can
see the moment it hit here and now
weekly pay has fallen away and currently
stands at about 11 pounds 61 an hour but
of course some workers have fared far
worse than others seventy percent of
those in full-time work have actually
seen their pay go up by more than four
percent 4.1 percent to be precise but
when you factor in all full-time workers
that pay rise drops to just not point
one percent that's the one pound we're
talking about and it's the people who
are recently back into work or moving
between jobs that are really feeling the
pinch and there's also of course a big
difference between the public and
private sectors and it may not be the
difference that you are expecting
considering the focus on cutting back on
public spending but in that sector the
pay rise is actually higher at one
percent of course frozen there but still
greater than the pay rise in the private
sector of just not point seven percent
and where you live matters to the
majority of the higher salaries across
the country are paid into London to
Londoners and this map shows really how
extreme the problem is the red being
some of the highest salaries across the
country but another so-called problem
seems to actually be improving slightly
the gender pay gap has narrowed from ten
percent last year to nine point four
percent now so heck of a gap now the
worst paid professions are waiters and
bar staff and hairdressers but if you're
just in it for the money these are the
jobs to take two of them in the airline
industry air traffic controllers are the
highest
paid group in the UK pilots and CEOs
fare very well too